[Music]
well she has kept loyal fans on the edge
of their seats for months now but
finally adele announcing the new dates
for her residency right here in las
vegas now the big question is what do
her fans make of all of this victoria
saha spoke to some who say they held
onto their tickets really just as long
as they could but now they're not sure
about making plans to return to las
vegas to see her
hello it's adele she's finally coming to
las vegas after all these months of
keeping fans waiting it's no secret her
original residency tickets were hard to
come by only to be canceled 24 hours
before opening night back in january on
monday morning social media blew up
after adele announced her residency at
caesars coliseum was back on saying in
part now i know for some of you it was a
horrible decision on my part and i will
always be sorry for that but i promise
you it was the right one like you had to
basically
win a chance to buy tickets and then the
tickets just said
postponed no other information danielle
boffinger from philadelphia considers
herself a die-hard adele fan she even
has three adele tattoos and when she got
tickets for adele's residency she was
overjoyed but then wasn't sure what to
do after it was postponed i was just
like
the money is spent like
i'm just gonna hold on along with
adele's announcement came automatic
reschedule dates for those who had
tickets for her original residency but
for beaufinger her april concert date is
now scheduled for christmas weekend it's
hard to leave your kids on christmas and
then i thought
christmas traveling is expensive like
everything doubles at christmas i just
wish we could have got a chance to like
i don't know
pick the date beaufinger paid seventeen
hundred dollars for her adele tickets
plus another four thousand dollars for
flight and hotel when adele was first
supposed to perform now the mom of five
is still deciding whether it will be
feasible for her to attend the new
concert date victoria saha live local
now